[Música]
por eso
tipo hong kong 1 kg buenas noches a
todos me da mucho gusto de estar aquí
con ustedes
yo quiero
y decirles que muy pocas personas saben
que vivimos indígenas aquí en toluca
como san andrés san pablo san cristóbal
vivimos habitantes de origen otomí yo
soy de origen otomí soy toallita antonio
mejía gonzález
soy artesana madre y vivo en san
cristóbal huichochitlán y aquí de toluca
quiero compartirles algunas cosas de
nuestra cultura y sus riquezas
vivimos
varios pueblos indígenas aquí en toluca
como tome más agua la wicca en agua
también quiero decirles que a diferencia
de nosotros a los más aguas
somos más serios nuestra vestimenta
ellos utilizan colores más fuertes como
el rosa mexicano o el ruso
nosotros las mujeres otomíes usamos el
chin cuete que mide 4 metros de largo y
la acomodamos sus pliegues con la faja
la faja se ha utilizado siempre porque
anteriormente las mujeres realizaban
trabajos más pesados en el campo
ellas la utilizaba porque ellas se
encargaban
con los trabajos como la siembra y la
cosecha ahora utilizamos la faja como
parte de nuestra tradición
también usamos el rebozo que es la cuna
del bebé que las llevamos siempre unido
a nosotros a nuestra espalda
conocer nuestra lengua es importante
conocer nuestra cultura y lengua que los
niños otomíes no lo olviden
es muy importante preservar nuestra
lengua yo le invito a los niños de san
cristóbal y de toluca que no olviden la
lengua pues es importante dominando bien
el otomí pueden dominar cualquier otro
idioma
la importancia de las artesanías de aquí
de toluca nosotros trabajamos en san
cristóbal huichochitlán la palma como
parte artesanal
esta es nuestra fuente de trabajo
nosotros no trabajamos la palma
pero no es lo mismo trabajar una palma
cruda que una palma horneada
hornear la palma nosotros podemos rajar
la palma para un acabado
ya sea extrafino como ustedes lo verán
fino
o igual rústico
cada uno de estos tejidos lleva parte de
nuestra riqueza porque nosotros lo
elaboramos con mucho amor
cuando ustedes compran alguna artesanía
de palma es muy importante para nosotros
porque con eso nosotros mantenemos a
nuestra familia y es parte de nuestras
riquezas
sin las artesanías no seríamos nada esto
nos da nuestra identidad y no nada más
san cristóbal trabaja la artesanía está
san andrés san pablo santana metepec en
donde se trabaja el barro la palma
la resina y el barro
es muy importante
y muy valiosa nuestro trabajo pues no es
de molde ni mucho menos es de fábrica en
la cual ninguna otra pieza es igual a la
otra
también preservar las técnicas
artesanales
es muy importante
para nosotros nos da nuestra identidad
pero yo le invito a cada uno de ustedes
aquí elaboran algo manual que es parte
de nosotros
y además
y eso lo hacemos con nuestras ideas yo
en lo personal he dado curso he
capacitado a personas para que nuestras
artesanías no se pierdan
porque es una de nuestras mayores
riquezas
sin las artesanías como se nos había
dicho no seríamos
yo quiero invitarles que olviden un poco
en un momento el celular
y adán
algún trabajo manual creativa
hamadi
y negocio y you got to be kirchner
estuvo era he sido bueno muchas gracias
a todos
también quiero compartir con ustedes lo
que es la canción lo que es una canción
no tome y se llaman los ojitos verdes
me hizo a este como todo el mundo
yo vine la víctima queso davín y tobin y
inauguran gatti existido muerte
yo y gas y corona y hawit oso y negrito
allí ella
a por ello
no crecidos y jardines donde sí
hoy yo yo yo
por ello
no he sido en suministros de vivir
son insólitas pero hamás y muy poco
[Música]
puedan yo pósito peso pesado
luego más a john barrasso castilla y
laurel
también es muy dramático he sido
y hoy no haya agüere yo nunca he sido sí
que he vivido un hogar
oye yo yo
el agüere yo no he sido yo he visto de
mini
camarillo muchas gracias